hello everyone and welcome to the
matchup you've all been waiting for it
is the finals of the Julius bar
generation cup and it is the alireza
Fury versus Magnus cross and now I
always like to remind people that when
we're covering this event that this is
the final event not the Grand Final so
there is uh another final that comes
after this one uh and whoever loses the
final can still bounce back and you know
face off against the the winner of the
final in the Grand Final it's confusing
but I've also learned that some other
sports use this as well now let's check
it out uh we're only going to show one
of the three games I thought this one
was absolute Madness you guys will enjoy
this one so many variations
um I mean it's just uh as the title
suggests uh if uh you know if you play
really well you should crush your
opponent but you have to find some
really disgusting engine lines uh so I'm
not gonna tell you what happened in the
actual uh matchup we're gonna discuss
this after we check out the game so all
it is it has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 Magnus of course we all
know what he replies with Pawn C5 he
goes for the Sicilian Defense Knight F3
E6 and now Pawn to D for the open
Sicilian uh captures captures and now
Knights to C6 that was a knight captures
on D4 if anyone is uh you know just
listening not watching by any chance
Knight the C3 and now Queen to C7 going
for the boss Rico variation of the Timon
of Sicilian Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to
A6 we have Queen to F3 Knight to F6 and
now Queen side castles and this is what
we've been played before nothing new
here like 200 games in the database only
in top tier tournaments uh Knight to E5
attacking the queen and queen to G3
aligning nicely with the black queen
here and usually B5 is the move here
it's pretty much exclusively uh played
here sometimes okay you do you do have a
knight F coming to G4 uh sorry the the
G4 but Magnus plays Pawn to H5 and this
was never played in top tier tournaments
there are like five games
um uh from lower rated tournaments where
this was attempted but you will see just
how much poison there is to this move
now if you really want to punish black
if you really know your stuff and if you
if you really know how to punish this
move by heart then the chances are you a
top Grand Master
uh such as alireza might not notice as
you really don't expect someone to play
it against you but you should play Pawn
to F4 uh this is one of the lines that
is really strong against Pawn to H5
point being that now after the Knight
moves and attacks is the bishop you will
play Ponte E5 attack the other Knight
and now after Knight captures Queen
captures and the other Knight comes to
G4 to attack the queen you will play
Queen to F3 again you are stopping B5 as
The Rook on A8 would hang so Pawn to D5
and now you kick away the Knight now of
course black does not have to react to
this because if captures captures your
queen will hang and also the Rook so
black will just move the bishop Bishop
D7 you will continue development now the
Knight has to move as the Rooks are
defending each other so Knight H6 and
now Queen captures on H5 and it's a free
Pawn it's a free Pawn it's a better
position for white and that's how you
should play against this but alireza
started thinking here and he played the
second strongest move recommended by the
engine and a much much cooler one he
played Knight D to B5 5 he attacked the
black queen and sacrificed his Knight
now why did he do this well because the
black queen is tied to the defense of
the E5 Knight so the black queen will
have to retreat to the B8 Square so this
is what happened eight captures on B5
Knight captures now the queen has to go
to B8 to defend to keep defending the
Knight and now alireza played Bishop to
B6 with the terrible threat of not
Knight to C7 check but Bishop to C7 and
this will trap The Black Queen here at
Magnus played Knight captures on e4 he
attacked alirez's Queen and alireza
played Queen to E3 and now uh magnus's
Knight is hanging an also magnus's Queen
could very easily be trapped but what
does Magnus play Magnus plays Rook
characters on A2 now what this does is
uh two things first it gives the black
queen d8 Square to escape if you try to
trap it with Bishop to C7 but even
better if you actually play Bishop to C7
which now makes no point okay you could
maybe play to attack the queen and the
Knight here uh Rook A1 is Checkmate as
the Knight and E4 also covers the Escape
Square for the king so you have to be
very careful here so after Rook captures
an A2 oh it is a plate King to B1 it is
the absolute best move and now we have
uh Rook to A4 and here with this Rook to
A4 move uh alireza is completely
completely winning here but you have to
uh you have to find the correct set of
moves Knight the C7 check was played uh
and here uh the the the engine actually
says the game is so lost for Magnus that
he should just give up his Queen but the
position is so complicated that Magnus
doesn't do this so I'm just going to
show you what you sort of should play
Queen captures the bishop captures now
Knights the G4 you go after the F2
Square so we're gonna win some more
material drill after the queen moves to
attack The Rook here you go Rook to B4
you attack the queen and once the queen
moves now you play Rook to D4 even you
attack the queen and the rook and D1 and
now after the queen moves let's say
queen to F3 uh this is the pretty much
the last thing you can do Rook captures
Queen captures and now Knight captures
um on F2 to attack the queen and the
Rook the queen will move to a nice
centralized square and now Knight
captures on each one so not the great uh
and the Bishops are not developed on
another Rook so uh White is still much
better here but maybe black will be able
to play if uh White plays a couple of
silly moves and black gets to developer
but Magnus doesn't even play the
strongest move recommended by the engine
which is giving up the queen Magnus
plays King to E7 and now all there is
this position is completely winning uh
but you have to find uh well it's uh
it's very difficult what you have to
find so feel free to pause the video
here and to win the game for alireza
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
incredibly weird idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to B3 this is the move that
wins the game and the only move that
wins the game so you attack The Rook
here you invite Knight captures on F2
but the problem is after Knight captures
an F2 and queen captures an A4 Knight
captures on D1 now the point of it all
is Knight to B5 and now uh there is no
move black can make the stop Bishop to
C7 uh the the pawns and the bishop here
are are you know really poorly placed uh
there is no move you could you could
play at the Block Bishop the C7 the
queen controls the a file completely uh
the Knight and Bishop work really well
and Bishop to C7 on the next move will
win the black queen so that's pretty
much it however uh Magnus was able to
trickle it is uh after King the E7
alireza played Rook to D4 uh he defended
and now he forces a rook trade and uh
this allows Magnus to really come back
into the game characters on D4 Queen
captures on D4 and now Pawn to F6 this
was the move that Magnus needed to
bounce back he wants to give back
material the Knight will be excellently
centralized here that the D5 is coming
and then the bishop the king is coming
to F7 then the Bishops can be developed
and his position will uh come alive so
Queen captures an E4 well it is a has to
take material there's nothing better D5
now Queen back to E1 and King to F7 now
the bishop could come into the game uh
F4 attacking the Knight but Magnus does
not move the Knight it would be uh it
would be a poor choice of moves if you
actually uh did something with the
Knight Bishop to D6 is best develop
while attacking so Knights the B5
attacks the bishop but now just Knights
the C6 we have Pawn to G3 to defend the
F4 pawn and now Bishop to D7 Magnus just
nicely continues developing and now
magnus's pieces are pretty much
developed you still need to get the rook
in their game but one thing you can
realize is that Magnus is now up upon
and that's a problem and all it is is
really really down on time by a lot so
Queen to D2 by alireza and now onto H4
uh we have Bishop to G2 not just H
captures and G3 H captors Rook captures
an H1 Bishop captures and Bishop to B4
Magnus is very happy trading as many
pieces as possible Queen to H2 and now
Knights the E7
uh we have Knights the D4 now uh and the
queen to D6 just going after the bishop
here so Queen to H5 would check King to
f8 and now Bishop to d8 uh the problem
is uh if you go Queen to h8 then Knights
the G8 uh blocks check and there is no
good continuation so Bishop to C5 now
attacks the Knight Queen to HH check
Knights the G8 and now Knights to B3 so
now allereza has to try and defend this
being down upon uh with Bishop to B6 and
now Bishop captures and B6 Magnus again
happily trading more pieces uh we have
Pawn to F5 LEDs are trying to create
some sort of a breakthrough here in
order to attack the black king of course
if one captures then the bishop captures
then you might be able to do something
but Magnus just plays Queen G1 checking
the A2 and now Queen captures and G3
winning yet another pawn and now
capturing here doesn't really do all
that much because Bishop captures
defends the pawn defends the Knight and
everything is perfectly fine so alireza
goes Knight C5 he goes after the bishop
but now just the queen D6 you have to
keep the D6 on defended and that's
pretty much all there is to it you are
up to pawns so uh you know a few more
moves and uh you should be able to prove
your advantage upon characters on F6 and
E6 Bishop capture is now Knight back to
D3 uh all trades favor Magnus so alireza
has no option but to go back with Bishop
to F5 and now Queen to H5 we have
Knights to E7 now uh Queen back to h8
with King to F7 and queen to H5 with
check with Bishop to G6 and now uh Queen
back to E2 Queen to A6 would check with
King to B1 and now more trades are
coming Bishop captures and the three C
captures and now Queen to E6 um just
offering further trades so that's
basically the idea here Magnus is up two
pawns and he's constantly offering more
trades in order to improve his position
and maximize his Advantage so here we
have Queen to H5 check G6 Queen to H7
check King to E8 and now Bishop to F3 so
of course I it is I will check that
black ink as much as possible before
finally throwing in the towel King 37
with Bishop to D1 and now Queen to E1
you have to of course defend King to C1
Queen to E3 check with King to C2 and
now Pawn to G5 now of course simplest
way to win is to just push those pawns
to Victory we have Queen to h8 and now
Pawn to F5 with Queen to B8 going after
the pawn here on the B6 the queen nicely
defends it now comes King to C3 and
queen to C5 with check King goes back to
D2 and now comes Queen to B4 with check
King to C2 and now Pawn to G4 now the
queen is excellently placed here
defending here defending the king side
also putting pressure on the white king
not much you can do here with white uh
we have King to be one violidas and now
comes Queen to D4 the final centralizing
move before you continue pushing uh King
to A2 and now even Knights the C6 maybe
you can even Checkmate the white king
queen B7 check with King to D6 and now
Queen to a H7
uh Knight the B4 width check King to A3
Knight captures and D3 wins another pawn
queen to H6 with check King to E5 and
now Queen to H2 with check with King D4
Magnus not afraid to come deeper into
the position as he has all of these
pawns defending his king queen to G2
check with King F4 Queen to D2 with
check and now Queen to E3 we have Queen
to H2 check and he was in this position
on move 65 upon playing a queen to each
to check that alireza Felicia resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here once King to G5 is played
there are no more checks and it's very
well it's impossible to even find the
move for white you could maybe play
Queen D6 the threaten some checks
although there really aren't any like
you could maybe threaten Queen to d8 to
check but then just Queen the C5 check
forces a queen trade and again now you
have completely winning position three
pawns though Four Points to one and if
you try something like King A2 to avoid
any nasty discoveries that were coming
as the King was on A3 then you can even
deliver check midnight before check King
to B1 Queen to D3 check and now you
either pick up the bishop or if King
defends Knight to A2 with a beautiful
Checkmate so after Queen Dage to check
uh the talireza played uh also he
resigned the game and this was game two
and Magnus won it now what happened in
the rest of the match I will now say it
so if you don't want to know you know
don't um watch anymore Magnus won the
first game this one alireza could have
won had he found that Queen to B3 move
but uh Magnus also wanted Ending game
three Magnus was also Victorious so he
takes down alireza with a result of
three to zero uh but like I said this is
only the final we still have the Grand
Final we'll see if alireza will be able
to uh you know claw his way out from the
losers bracket and the joint Magnus in
the Grand Final or will it be someone
else
as well I mean a really really a crazy
game where Magnus employed this H5 idea
that does not work and should not and
will never be played like in In
classical chess also maybe it's one of
the reasons why Magnus is so much
against classical chess uh you could
never play this move uh you know in In
classical chess but in lower time
formatting and this is if this isn't
really even that fast I mean it's ten
plus two uh so players of this caliber
have time to calculate but it was not
enough time to calculate everything that
you should have calculated here like as
I went for this very very attractive
line and he even did everything he could
but here uh after uh after this King D7
was played we've shown I mean we should
have given another queen but you know if
you find uh Queen to B3 then it's game
over like we said once you reach this
position just Knight B5 and there's
nothing you can do to stop uh this uh
move I mean uh Bishop to C7 such a
spectacular idea but okay I mean so many
so many cool lines a Magnus Bluffs his
way and takes down well a former 2800
player holidays are firuja brilliant
brilliant stuff and yeah he wins the
match three to zero so we'll see who uh
who shall face Magnus in the Grand Final
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank the
etheriora.com India Moon India is the
best Crazy Dave and crazier day for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day